The Schrodinger Equation is the key equation
in quantum physics that explains how particles
in quantum physics behave.
You wanna know where your electron is going
to go?
That’s the Shrodinger equation you’ll
need.
So why does it look so complicated?
Well it’s because in quantum physics, when
you are describing what a thing like an electron
will do, it doesn’t follow the rules of
particles it follows the rules of waves, and
that’s what these psi’s are, they are
wavefunctions.
Okay so an electron is a wave, and a wave
can evolve in space and in time, but it can’t
evolve in any old way, there are constraints
about how it can evolve, and those constraints?
That’s what the Shrodinger equation is telling
us.
It says that over time (that’s this bit)
the total energy has to stay the same.
And this total energy is made of the kinetic
energy (that’s this bit), and potential
energy (that’s this bit).
An example of a potential energy for an electron
is just being in an atom.
So if you want to see what a quantum object
will do in the future, you need to find the
wavefunction that will satisfy all these bits
of the Shrodinger equation.